Electricity is all around us all the time.
It makes our lives easier, safer,
more fun than most of us never think about it.
But is there such a thing as too much Alec Tricity could?
The thing that is the foundation of the modern world slowly be killing us
Before we dive deeper.
Let's try to understand what electricity is and how it affects us.
Electricity is the movement of an electric charge.
This movement generates electric and magnetic fields that spread out through
space and carry energy. We call this phenomenon,
electromagnetic radiation.
Radiation is a word that makes people very nervous,
but to radiate just means giving off,
like when the radiator in your house gives off heat in the form of infrared
radiation,
different parts of the electromagnetic spectrum correspond to different types of
radiation. And many of them are perfectly harmless.
Some of them can be dangerous though.
Radiation with very short wavelengths like UV light x-rays and gamma rays
are strong enough to rip electrons out of their atoms,
which can cause burns and genetic damage.
This is what many people have in mind when they hear the term radiation,
the rest of the spectrum covers a large range of longer waves from visible light
infrared microwaves to radio waves.
This is the kind of radiation that's emitted by all sorts of human technology,
mobile phones, Li-Fi rouges electric power lines and household appliances.
This radiation doesn't disrupt molecules in our body. However,
some kinds of radiation can stimulate muscles and nerves and can also make the
hair on your body vibrate,
which can sometimes cause 18 B feeling above certain threshold values.
Other kinds of useful for making dinner, microwaves,
push the water molecules in your food around, which warms it up.
This happens to us all the time. For example,
the pleasant warmth you feel at the beach is your skin heating up from exposure
to electromagnetic infrared radiation from the sun.
We are surrounded by natural and generally harmless sources of electromagnetic
radiation all the time and always have been.
But since the industrial revolution,
we have added a lot of it to our immediate environment.
The question of whether this is actually dangerous first got public attention.
When a 1979 study linked to leukemia to living near power lines.
This particular study was quickly discredited though.
The connection could not be explained and low direct causal link was confirmed,
but once this had been proposed,
the idea persisted and the thousands of studies about possible dangers
illustrate that it's still seen as a very real threat.
A lot of people came to be sensitive to the radiation coming from our appliances
and cell phones. They report symptoms like headaches, nausea,
skin reactions, burning eyes or exhaustion,
but those are just effects reported on a day-to-day basis.
A few studies have found much more unsettling results like possible connections
between the side of the brain,
which people use when they're on their phones and the appearance of brain
tumors.
The question that science is trying to answer is not so much about the acute
effects of irradiation. We know, for example,
that x-rays cause immediate damage to the DNA in your cells,
but that the same doesn't happen with radio waves.
The question is rather is the sort of weak electromagnetic radiation.
We are constantly surrounded by harmful in the long run as a result of some
as yet unknown mechanism answering this question was much harder than
we first thought. There are thousands of primary sources, reports,
and statements by an onslaught of different organizations.
So we read a lot for this video.
You can take a look at our research in the video description.
What we found is that this debate is a good example of how science should be
communicated and how it shouldn't.
Many of the much cited studies that spread panic about electromagnetic radiation
are highly controversial. For example,
a series of population studies based on surveys.
And self-reporting what this means is for example,
asking brain tumor patients,
how much they think they use their phone in the last few years,
the problem is that people are unreliable.
We tend to misremember things or can be influenced easily.
On top of this studies or media reports may be cherry picking the findings that
best suit their opinion, or make the most exciting headline. For example,
a study looking for cancer in rats and mice from cell phone radiation,
the results seemed to show a connection,
but for some reason only in male rats and none at all in mice,
but it was reported as if this study did prove that mobile phone radiation
causes cancer. Unfortunately,
this is the case for studies with both positive and negative findings on the
issue. Another aspect is that the,
who did officially classify radio frequency fields as possibly
carcinogenic.
But what this actually means is that there are some hints that they might cause
cancer, but we can't prove it and that we will keep an eye out.
So if we zoom out a bit, what's the big picture on the whole.
There was no consistent evidence in human studies that electromagnetic radiation
below exposure value limits causes health problems.
There are some statistical associations,
but they're mostly weak and inconsistent.
If there were any definite cause effect relations we would know by now because
of all the data we have. So based on the current state of science,
should you worry about the radiation from your laptop or cell phone or TV?
The answer is no you shouldn't,
but what about the people that say is,
is harming them research showed that they could be experiencing,
what's known as the Nazi CBO effects.
If you have a headache and happened to start feeling better, right?
When you switch off your laptop,
you might see a connection between those two things.
Once you get this suspicion, the idea alone that week radiation might harm.
You could be the very thing harming you. It's easy to belittle these people.
Most of them feel they're not being taken seriously,
which makes the situation even worse for them. They should get support,
but it's important to be aware that so far we have no robust evidence that
electricity below safety limits has any negative effect on humans.
In the attention economy we live in talking about unproven.
Dangers can make us neglect things that we know for sure about for us.
Just one example,
outdoor air pollution is linked to 4.2 million premature deaths each year,
and is definitely something we could have a real impact on today still to
make people feel safe.
And just to make sure there are several long-term studies ongoing already.
For example,
the cosmos study that will look at the possible health impacts of cell phone use
by exactly measuring frequency and duration of phone calls.
But while we wait for the conclusion of these long-term studies,
there are a not more pressing problems to focus on.
Like instead of worrying what devices and networks do to your health,
consider how they can harm you. In other ways, when we shop online,
share photos or watch YouTube videos,
we leave a trail of accounts and passwords all over the internet.
Radio waves may not hurt us,
but people trying to take advantage of our data certainly will.
If a service becomes compromised, hackers can get your password.
And if you use the same login details, anywhere else,
they can easily slip in your other accounts. That's why we use Dashlane.
It's just one app to stay safe online on any device operating system or browser.
It creates a super strong, unique passwords,
but still lets you change them with just one click dash lane we'll even send you
breach alerts when sites you use get hacks and includes VPN for every device.
So you can securely browse from anywhere in the world like on your home wifi,
because we want you to have nice things.
You can get a 30 day free trial of Dashlane by going
to-lane.com/codes Cozart. If you like it, use the code [inaudible] at checkout.
The first 200 people will get 10% off.